they say a programmer some who cannot do
the same thing twice
so it's not the second time you write a
program to do it and I wish I could do
that for my own existence I could just
like you know figure out things keep
improving improving improving and once
I've nailed it let the AI loose on that
and maybe even let the AI better it
better than I could have but doesn't the
concept of you said me and I can work on
new things but doesn't that uh break
down because you said digital twin but
there's no reason it can't be
millions of digital milosas
aren't you lost in the sea of minosis
the original uh is hardly the original
it's just one of millions I
I want to have the room to grow
maybe the new version of me that that
that the actual me will get slightly
worse sometimes slightly better other
times when it gets slightly better I'd
like to emulate that and have a much
higher standard to meet and keep going
but does it make you sad that your loved
ones
physical real loved ones my kind of like
start cheating on you with the other
minosis I I want to be there 100 of them
for each of them
so I I have zero perks or zero zero
queer quirms about me being physically
me like zero jealousy wait a minute but
is isn't that like
don't we hold on to that isn't that why
we're afraid of death we don't want to
lose this thing we have going on isn't
that an ego death when there's a bunch
of other menoses you get to look at them
they're not you
they're just very good copies of you
they get to live a life
the I mean it's fear of missing out it's
fomo they get to have interactions I and
you don't get to have those interactions
there's two aspects of every person's
life there's what you give to others and
there's what you experience yourself
yeah
life truly ends when you experiencing
ends
but the others experiencing you doesn't
need to end ah
but your experience you could still I
guess you're saying the digital twin
does not limit your ability to truly
experience to experience as a human
being the the the the downside is when
you know my wife or my kids will have a
really emotional interaction with my
digital twin and I won't know about it
so I will show up and they now have the
baggage but I don't
so basically what makes interactions
between humans unique in this sharing
and exchanging kind of way is the fact
that we are both shaped by every one of
our interactions I think the model of
the digital twin works for dissemination
of knowledge of advice
Etc where you know I want to have wise
people give me advice across history I
want to have chat with Gandhi but Gandhi
won't necessarily learn from me
but I will learn from him so in a way
you know the dissemination and the
democratization rather than the building
of relationships so the the emotional
aspect is that there should be an alert
when the AI system is interacting with
your loved ones and all of a sudden it
starts getting like
emotionally fulfilling like a magical
moment there should be okay stop AI
system like freezes there's an alert on
your phone you need to take over yeah
yeah I take over and then whoever I was
speaking with they can have the the AI
or like one of the AI this is such a
tricky thing to get right I mean it's
still well I mean there's go
uh this is going to go wrong in so many
interesting ways that we're gonna have
to learn as a society yeah yeah that in
the process of trying to automate our
tasks and having a digital twin
you know for me personally if I could
have a relatively good copy of myself
uh I would set it to start answering
emails but I would start setting to
start tweeting I would like to replace
it gets better what if that one is
actually way better than you yeah
exactly then you're like uh well I
wouldn't want that because why
because then I would never be able to
live up to like what if the people that
love me start loving that thing and then
I'm I will always I already fall short
be falling short even more so listen I'm
a professor the stuff that I give to the
world is the stuff that I teach but most
much more importantly sorry number one
there's stuff that I teach number two
the discoveries that we make in my
research group but much more importantly
the people that I train
they are now out there in the world
teaching others
if you look at my own trainees they are
extraordinarily successful professors
so Andrew kundaji at Stanford Alex Stark
at Imp in Vienna Jason Ernst at UCLA
Andrea spending at CMU
each of them I'm like wow they're better
than I am
and I love that
so maybe your role
will be to train better versions of
yourself
and they will be your legacy not you
doing everything but you training much
better version of Lex Friedman than you
are
and then they go off to do their mission
which is in many ways what this
mentorship model of Academia does but
the legacy is ephemeral it doesn't
really live anywhere the Legacy it's not
like written somewhere it just lives
through them but you can continue
improving and you can continue making
even better versions of you
yeah but they'll do better than me and
that's creating you it's awesome but
it's
um
you know there's a ego that says there's
a value to an individual and it feels
like this process decreases the value of
the individual this meat bag
all right if there's good digital copies
of people then uh there's more
flourishing of human thought and ideas
and experiences but there's less value
to the individual human I I don't have
any such limitations I I basically I
don't I don't have that feeling at all
like I remember one of our interviews I
was basically saying you know the
meaning of life you had asked me and I
was like I came back and I was like I
felt useful today
and I was at my maximum I was I was you
know
like a hundred percent and I gave good
ideas and I was a good person with a
good advisor with a good husband a good
father that was a great day because it
was useful and if I can be useful to
more people by having digital twin I
will be liberated
because my urge to be useful
will will be satisfied
doesn't matter whether it's direct me or
indirect me whether it's my students
that I've trained my AI that I've
trained
I think there's a there's a sense that
my mission in life is being accomplished
and I can work on my self-growth
I mean that's a very Zen State that's
why people love you this is understand
you've achieved but do you think most of
humanity will be able to achieve that
kind of thing is the people people
really hold on to the value of Their Own
ego that's it's not just being useful
being useful is nice as long as it
builds up this reputation and that meat
bag is known as being useful therefore
has more value right people really don't
want to let go of that ego thing I I one
of the books that I reprogram my brain
with at night was called uh ego is the
enemy it goes in the atom ego is the
enemy and basically being able to just
let go like
uh my advisor used to say you can
accomplish anything
as long as you don't seek to get credit
for it
that's beautiful to hear especially from
a person who's existing in Academia
you're right the Legacy lives through
the people you mention it's the actions
it's the outcome